in the opening scene we are introduced
to a man named Armin who is conducting
interviews with high-ranking officials
armin's lack of experience becomes
evident as he struggles to handle the
camera and properly focus on his
subjects once he is done Armin reports
his work to his Superior only to realize
that the camera had not been in
recording mode the entire time this
infuriates the boss causing him to storm
out of the room following this we are
introduced to our protagonist properly
Armin is an aimless Bachelor who is
struggling financially and lives alone
in a small apartment he displays a lack
of understanding when it comes to women
as demonstrated when he invites a girl
named Rosa to his place in an attempt to
create a romantic atmosphere he plays
pre-coital music
what like Coldplay however when Rosa
requests to use his toothbrush Armin
refuses and instead offers her a new one
that's what I would have done but this
action upsets Rosa leading her to leave
without saying anything in the next
scene Armin visits his parents house in
order to see his grandmother who is
bedridden armin's personal life is
dysfunctional because his father has
abandoned his mother and he is now with
his younger lover named Lilo Stitch is
gonna beat his ass that night Armand
stays with his grandmother rests his
head on her shoulder and provides her
with Comfort assuring her that
everything will be okay the next evening
Armin decides to visit his biological
mother even though his father does not
want him to he believes that his mother
is waiting for him after a long drive he
arrives at his mother's Place only to
discover that she is having a good time
with her friends the site leaves him
feeling rejected and he quietly departs
with tears in his eyes he then drives to
a river Coast where he sees people
joyfully enjoying a cruise party which
intensifies his feelings of loneliness
the fall following morning Armin wakes
up in his car and decides to go to the
nearby grocery store to purchase some
food upon entering he realizes that the
store is deserted he looks around and
calls out for the cashier but no one is
there to respond to him as a result he
grabs some items and leaves money on the
cashier's table as a generous gesture
exiting the grocery store he notices a
few motorbikes and cars with their
engines still running at the gas station
however he does not pay much attention
and drives away gradually Armin starts
feeling a sense of unease due to the
completely empty roads shortly after he
comes across several abandoned scooters
in the middle of the road feeling an
eerie sensation he tries to contact his
father but fails to reach him Panic sets
in so he rushes back to his father's
place upon arrival he finds the door
locked from the inside prompting him to
knock where he builds as there is no
response and this leads him to
forcefully break the entrance door
inside he only discovers the lifeless
body of his grandmother lying on the bed
this freaks him out and he starts
screaming for help but once again no one
one response left with no choice he
enters the house of a neighbor named
lothar but only finds the family dog
Cosmo unable to comprehend what is
happening Armin returns helmet Ponders
to himself his confusion heightens when
he realizes that his phone has no
Network signal and the water taps have
run dry before long he hears a noise
coming from the entrance Door upon
checking on it he discovers Cosmo who is
injured and in its final moments
believing that someone is responsible
for all of this Armin grabs a rifle and
heads to lothar's house to confront the
presumed Intruder however his assumption
proves to be wrong as he finds no one
there the next morning Armin improvises
a shower using a bottle of water and
proceeds to carry out his grandmother's
final ritual for this he collects all
the books copies and papers places them
beneath his grandmother's bed douses
them in gasoline and sets them Ablaze
with a lighter after this he heads out
on a drive along an empty Rural Road
encountering numerous abandoned vehicles
along the way soon after he comes across
an upscale police sports car Armin who
has never ridden any luxurious cars in
his life immediately gets inside the car
and thoroughly enjoys the ride in it
after a while he enters a tunnel where
he discovers an overturned truck housing
trapped horses feeling bad for them he
immediately frees the animals from their
confinement
the scene then cuts to a few years later
and we see that Armin is living his life
like a farmer he has constructed a
wooden dwelling somewhere in the woods
of the desolated world where he rears
various birds and animals such as
chickens Ducks horses and goats it
becomes evident that he is adapted to
solitary living as he sews clothes on
his own searches for food and cares for
his Animal Companions apart from all
this he even works on his new invention
to generate electricity with the help of
water from the nearby River one night
while sleeping Armin is awakened by the
sounds of a Restless goat hey I can't
sleep upon checking on it he discovers
that the goat is in the midst of giving
birth Armin Witnesses the entire
birthing process and experiences a
profound sense of Joy however his
happiness is short-lived as the baby
goat is snatched away by a jackal the
very next morning feeling bad for the
mother goat Armin chases after The
Jackal with his gun but his efforts
prove fruitless disheartened he returns
empty-handed and sits with the mother
goat for a while contemplating the loss
one particular day Armin rides on his
horse and Ventures into the woods to
scavenge for necessary Goods as he
enters deep into the woods he along with
his horse is suddenly attacked by a wild
dog reacting swiftly Armin shoots the
dog but in the process he falls from his
horse and sustains a head injury causing
him to lose Consciousness after a while
we see someone arriving at the scene
with a flashlight and observing the
injured Armin in the morning Armin
regains Consciousness only to find
himself wrapped in aluminum foil keeping
him warm he has no idea how he ended up
like this thinks for a while and then
makes his way back to his dwelling later
in the evening Armand notices a station
wagon approaching his place suspicious
that it may be a Potential Threat he
grabs a rod as his weapon and hides
himself behind a bush soon after a woman
named Kirsty approaches him wielding a
shotgun demanding he relinquish his
weapon the latter is too scared to
attack so he complies and throws the rod
aside here she also lowers her firearm
and walks back to her vehicle the next
morning Armin wakes up and discovers a
breakfast beside him as he tastes the
food he finds it remarkably delicious as
it has been a long time since he last
enjoyed such a meal a few moments later
Kirsty walks in and notices a wound on
his leg recognizing its severity she
retrieves first aid supplies from her
vehicle and tends to his injury later as
they sit down for a cup of coffee Kirsty
inquires why Armin chose to reside in
this remote location instead of an urban
area in response he explains that this
place holds a sense of belonging for him
he then asks if Kirsty has encountered
any other humans to which she replies
that he is the first one as their
conversation continues Armin reaches out
and touches her hand relishing the
sensation of human contact after a long
time delighted to have found each other
they then share a passionate kiss and
eventually become intimate from that
they forward they establish a life
together as a couple residing in armin's
self-built home in the next scene we see
Kirsty and Army toiling in the field
engrossed in their work amidst their
labor keirsi opens up about her
harrowing experience in Syria she
recounts as she found herself stranded
in the vast Syrian desert when her
vehicle broke down and during three
agonizing days without a single drop of
water in addition Kirsty confides her
desire to visit Berlin but Armin
dismisses the city considering it boring
and unappealing whereas zarmin is a
goddamn party animal apart from their
daily activities Armin also devotes his
time and energy to his latest invention
harnessing the power of river water to
generate electricity despite
encountering numerous setbacks and
failures he perseveres and eventually
achieves success producing an adequate
power supply for their home as the days
pass the couple of appears to be living
a happy life together they work hard in
the fields share meals and relish
moments of leisure such as swimming in
the nearby River however their happy
life begins to suffer when Armin
expresses his desire to have a child
Kirsty vehemently opposes the idea
saying that she doesn't want to bring a
child into this apocalyptic world when
Armin continues persisting she becomes
angry and abruptly departs leaving him
alone once again Hermann just wants to
give the baby to the goat the following
evening his Armin sits down to have his
meal his attention is drawn to a
recreational vehicle that arrives near
his dwelling intrigued he Ventures
outside to investigate only to find
Kirsty in the vehicle with a dog as the
two chat keirsi reveals fragments of her
past life she discloses that she had
been deeply in love with the man for
seven years and was looking forward to
starting a family with him however he
continuously urged her to wait leaving
her in a state of uncertainty then one
fateful day his son unexpectedly arrived
at their doorstep Kirsty says that she
had spent seven years of her life with a
man without truly knowing him resulting
in a heartbreak break that forever
changed her perspective this experience
seems to have transformed her into a
resilient and independent individual
additionally Kirsty expresses her desire
to travel to the South with Armin
however he politely declines saying he
cannot leave his beloved animals behind
later the pair drives to the nearby
grocery store looking to get some
beverages Armin is happy at kirsty's
return so he turns on some music and
begins dancing with her after enjoying
the moment for a while the two of them
make their way back home with Armin
looking joyful but Kirsty seeming sad
something is clearly bothering her on
their way a tire on their RV suddenly
punctures seeing this Kirsty asks Armin
to repair the tire by the following
morning revealing her intention to leave
this makes Armin sad and he inquires if
she will return Kirsty simply says don't
wait for me as night falls she goes to
bed but Armin is restless he just stands
before her and keeps staring at her
beautiful face in the morning Kirsty
awakens and prepares a cup of coffee for
herself just then she finds armin's
recipe book which grabs her attention
going through its Pages she stumbles
upon a photograph of Armin alongside his
grandmother which makes her smile in a
final twist it is revealed that it's
actually her grandmother too and she is
armin's Sister gotcha
at the same time Armin brings her RV
back after successfully solving the tire
issue handing her the vehicle keys he
cautions her not to exceed a speed of
80. as the tires might experience
instability shortly after Armand and
Kirsty share a kiss one last time and
she expresses her gratitude to him for
fixing her tires and allowing her to
leave as she prepares to drive away
Armin stops her not wanting to be alone
again he makes an impulsive decision to
go along with her he asks for her to
just wait a minute so that he can free
all of his animals with this request he
starts opening all the cages and sets
the animals loose but as he does this
Kirsty suddenly drives away leaving him
behind holy crap that twit that twist
wasn't a joke
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching